if I ever want to network with somebody
who's above me in status when I approach
those calls I approach them as customers
in my mind even if I never think I'm
going to do business with them if you're
going to do a favor for someone do a
capital f favor so one of the biggest
things I see is people want to start
some sort of reciprocal relationship so
they do a little bit for free and
they're like look I gave them some value
give him some good will right but if
you're really going to do it and you
actually think the relationship is worth
investing in then do what you would
normally do if you actually charge them
for the work and then deliver that the
reaction you want from the other person
is like whoa this is too much I can't
believe you did all that that is how you
take one step forward into a
relationship where you might be
underneath them is that you provide so
much more value that they feel indebted
to you anyone can do this no matter how
far ahead someone else is than you